so nice to be here I have had a few
white wines sure I like white wine it's
my favorite drink I think it should be a
class a drug though because it makes you
go mental
don't mean you have a be like I feel
good you have a white wine you liar I'm
gonna text him I'm gonna clarify
something you said in 2017 why not yes
my parents are divorced obviously I
didn't mind it so much I think the worst
thing about your parents getting
divorced is that they move into two
different houses and then you as the kid
has to move from house to house
I remember being little thinking why
can't I stay here and you guys move to
me why am i five years old learning how
to roll my socks to fit more room in the
suitcase cuz dad kissed a woman at a
party now I get there he's like oh you
forgot your toothbrush I'm like dual you
forgot your wedding vows my mom called
me the other day actually she said oh I
think I think you've got this tyroid
disease a lot of the women in our family
have got it you've got all those
symptoms you've got weight fluctuation
you've got skin prone to breakouts and
you're quite irritable and rude well I
hope I've got it otherwise it's been
quite a mean phone call
a bit of a mug off it happens a bit like
I my friends and I we have this thing we
call it the abomination theory it's this
theory that we've figured out that in
this world there's you and then there's
people look like you but better
there's people look at you but a bit
worse and we call them your abomination
and what we do is every time we see each
other's abomination is we'll give each
other a call and I got a call the other
day from my friend he said I just saw
your abomination worst one yet this is
real sweaty she was carrying two plastic
bags full of chicken just kind of
running along this street and I said
what was that like an hour ago
thank you maybe I should stop answering
the farm addicted to my phone I think so
many people are it causes people so much
anxiety a lot of people are trying to
get off their phones using different
methods my friend she's downgraded from
her smartphone to a flip phone she came
over the other day we're going out to
eat she's like yeah I've got a flip
phone it's awesome I'm not checking my
emails I'm not scrolling through
Instagram comparing my life to other
people's it's so good I feel so in the
moment I was like okay cool I guess I'm
getting the uber it really just sort of
outsourced your anxiety to me there have
it you she's sort of skipping off like a
free little fairy I'm trying to find out
where North is fun fun for me but she
also her dog is on antidepressants yeah
it's weird because the narrative of the
dog is that they're quite happy and you
know I think it kind of makes sense like
when I get bored sometimes I get
depressed and I think these dogs they're
so smart you know they descended from
wolves they used to be hunting stuff I
don't know but now then now they just
sort of sit on the couch they were in
wearing little jackets we treat them
like idiots were like you're a dog
they're so smart you know dogs can
they're sorry somehow they can smell up
to four different types of cancer in the
human body I know I can't tell you about
it though
I mean maybe that's why they're so
depressed they're just sitting there
with the weight of the world on their
shoulders and again we treat them like
idiots well I always don't piss on the
wrong it's like [ __ ] you've got cancer
[Applause]
Stage four not that I want them I don't
know if I want them to talk I don't
because I think the best thing about
having a dog is that you can sit there
and complete silence it's beautiful yeah
like why would you want awkward silence
with yet another thing in your life I
don't know Coenen you've got have you
got a dog I have two dogs what are their
names
Bosco and Loki Bosco and Logie and you
ever wish you could talk to them yeah
it'd be fun to know what they're up to
yeah I guess I disagree I think cuz I
mean what if Bosco and lo you could talk
but you guys don't click like what if
you knew Bosco and like he could talk to
you and they won't I mean just they know
they're not either we don't click at all
yeah and you're trying to get it going
on the cat [ __ ] like hey boss what's
going to do um did you like that walk
before he's like yeah you asked us
earlier and you're like ok yeah whatever
look I got a guy I've got a doctor's
appointment he's like good luck that is
my time
[Applause]